politique le protocole rien que le
protocole la cérémonie d'investiture de
Jacques Chirac tout à l'heure à l'Élysée
a été sobre et brève proclamation des
résultats par le Conseil constitutionnel
et courte allocution du chef de l'État
Véronique Saint-Olive Didier rancœur
mesdames messieurs je vous demande de
bien vouloir rejoindre votre emplacement
indiqué au sol il s'agissait de faire
sobre le résultat a dépassé les
espérances cet après-midi dans la grande
salle des fêtes de l'Élysée on se serait
presque cru au musée Grévin d'un côté
bien aligné une petite soixantaine
d'invités représentant les corps
constitués de l'autre tous les ministres
au gardeà-vou pour se succéder à
lui-même et comme pour marquer que la
situation est difficile Jacques Chirac a
voulu le protocole tout le protocole
mais rien que le protocole vous avez
recueilli le 5 mai 2002
25537956 voix solennel le nouveau
président de la République a ensuite
réitéré la promesse du candidat rétablir
l'autorité de l'État
c'est une exigence majeure de ce
quinquena le rétablissement de la
sécurité des Français en
dépend l'action est lancée je m'y
attacherai personnellement et les
formalités se suivent présentation du
collier de grand maître de la Légion
d'Honneur félicitation
conjugal passage en revue des troupe
dans les jardins au loin 21 coups de
canon sont tirés des
Invalides que jacquesirac a bien succédé
à
jacquesirac